All right, awesome,
I get to tell you about coco values.
So coco stands for
cooperative-competitive values.
>> Coco stands for that?
>> Well, the coco part of coco value
stands for cooperative-competitive.
>> Okay.
>> And this is an idea due to Kalai and
Kalai because you need as
many of those as you can get.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Here is an example
of coco values that
feature some people
that you may recognize.
So this is Curly and
Smooth and the bananas.
So Curly and
Smooth would like to get bananas,
turns out Curly is too
short to get any bananas.
>> So true.
>> And Smooth is tall
enough to get two bananas.
>> Yeah, it's very.
>> But if Smooth stood on top of Curly's
head, then he could actually get four
bananas, he could reach these
two additional high bananas.
>> So it's like a Tuesday.
>> So
let's set this up as a matrix game.
Here's a matrix version of the game.
So this is suggest to you and
you have two choices.
You can just reach for
the bananas yourself, or
you could stand on the top of my
head and reach the other bananas.
>> So you're my friend in this.
>> Sorry, Curly,
you can stand on the top of Curly.
Not you, I mean Smooth can
stand on top of Curly's head.
>> Okay.
>> And Curly has the choice of either
[LAUGH] allowing that to happen or
not, okay.
>> I like this game.
>> Yeah.
Believe it or not, I did not make this
up for the purposes of this class.
And so
we can ask some questions about this.
So for example, what's the nash?
>> I'm sorry, you're actually
asking me [LAUGH] what the nash is?
I guess I should-
>> It's a rhetorical question,
except it's not rhetorical.
It's just a question.
>> Pure nash?
>> If you can find one, sure.
>> Okay, well, is there a pure nash?
I mean, I've just seen these numbers for
the first time.
>> Yeah, but you shouldn't.
Okay, sure.
>> So I can just ask the question,
all right so, if we do don't boost and
reach, would either want to move?
Well, it doesn't really matter
if you go from reach to climb.
You get the same value.
>> Right.
>> And
it doesn't matter if-
>> No, wait.
No, you, sorry, you, right, you, Smooth.
It doesn't matter to Smooth-
>> It doesn't matter to Smooth once if
you're in don't boost, reach, and
if you're in don't boost, reach,
it also doesn't, wait.
No, I'm sorry, I take that back.
>> It does matter.
>> It does matter,
I'm reading the numbers backwards.
So, the first one is for Curly, and
the second number's for Smooth.
>> See, I put them in the same order
as there, where they're standing.
>> That makes perfect sense.
So if you have 0,2, so then if we're
stuck on don't boost and Smooth can move
from reach to climb, Smooth would not do
that because you're going from 2 to 0.
Meanwhile, if we're in don't boost,
reach, and Curly can change,
then Curly would go from 0 to 0.
And it doesn't really make a difference.
I guess don't boost and
reach is a Nash equilibrium.
So, let's see, I think there's probably
there's a symmetry thing there.
So we know don't boost and
climb is not a Nash equilibrium.
For the same reason that 0,
2 is one, 0, 0 is not,
because I'd be going from
0 to 2 if I were Smooth.
So there's no point in
worrying about that.
What about boost and reach?
Well, let's see.
That's 0, 2, and so
Curly doesn't need to move,
doesn't have an advantage to
moving from boost to don't boost.
But Smooth would want to move because
you'd be going from 2 to 4, so
that is not Nash equilibrium.
>> Okay.
>> Now let's look at boost and climb, so
boost and climb, let's see, it's 0, 4.
So if I went from boost to don't boost,
I would still stay at 0, and
so that doesn't help Curly any.
And I wouldn't move from climb to reach
because I'd be going from 4 to 2, and
so therefore, that is also a Nash.
>> All right, now,
which Nash equilibrium do you
think would be more beneficial?
>> Well for Smooth,
it would definitely be boost and climb.
>> Yeah.
What about for like the society of these
two people, like if you just add
up the total retrieved bananas?
>> So that would be 2 versus 4.
>> Yeah.
>> So in fact again, boost and
climb would be,
on average, more benefit.
>> On average.
>> Or the sum for the society.
>> Yeah, right.
>> So on average is all the same thing.
>> Right, but it sort of doesn't matter
to Curly, but it would matter to Smooth,
and it's also the case that to Nash,
it doesn't really matter.
Both of these are Nash equilibrium, so
they're both perfectly acceptable from a
Nash equilibrium sort of point of view.
>> Yeah, this is like the example
that I did with chicken,
where you have two Nash equilibrium, and
they're both kind of equally
good from Nash's point of view.
Although in that case,
they're very different from
the two players' point of view.
Here, I suppose either way,
Curly gets nothing.
So really,
it's just about making Smooth happy.
I like this game.
>> [LAUGH] So okay, sure, fine.
So that being said, can we see
anything about correlated equilibria?
>> I mean, I'm sure we can, right?
We can, any makes Nash equilibrium
is a correlated equilibrium, but
I think this one's a little
different right here, right?
Because no matter what happens,
Curly gets 0.
>> So that means that anything's
going to be equally okay to Curly.
>> Right.
>> So Curly is not really
going to participate in
the equilibriumness or lack thereof.
>> Right, so really, this is all about
getting to boosting and climbing.
>> Yeah, though I think you said that
any convex combination of a Nash
is a correlated equilibrium.
>> That's right.
>> So it should be everything like 0, 2,
0 to 1, 0 to 2, 0 to 3, 0 to 4, 0 to 5,
0 to 6, all the way up to 0, 3, 0,4.
We know that all those have to be Nash,
correlated, they have to be a value of
some correlated equilibrium
that is like 0, 3, for example.